wir sind drei leute drin
warum sieht man ja natürlich
der prozess geht seien herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge hacker
schon heute mit einer speziellen
einsendung wenn ihr wissen wollt wie er
auch mal eine hecke schon dabei sein
könnt dann schaut und in die
beschreibung darf ich das alles noch mal
erklärt wir fangen jetzt an mit
einsendungen nummer 1 das heißt platz
nummer fünf das ist mal etwas anderes
und zwar von ze liegt ihr selbst im
hintergrund schon der hat mir ein video
zusammengestellt um einen hacker wissen
zu prüfen
2b ab und an mal so leute und wegen ich
hatte keine ahnung von hacks oder sowas
deswegen wir das noch mal testen das
video ist notenvergabe dieser kanal
unterstrich z elite sehr gute idee und
ich würde sagen wir technische abnahmen
hacker wissen hacker nummer eins okay
wer das jetzt aufgebaut sagte jetzt
hacker ok nike laura auf jeden fall
speed nordberg was waren das für hacks
nennen wir zwei hacks okay ich sagte
laura nordbeck swietek das ist schon 36
mal gucken mal gucken ob das passt
auflösung for speed pack antinac
baggergut mackey laura passt ja drei
haben schon auf jeden fall sehr gut okay
okay das auf jeden fall auch eine killer
meine auch nur noch weg gesehen zu haben
ja noch beck sicher sein alter fast
schon die gitarre sie komisch ja schon
ab werk ohne kilo eventuell noch
autoclick bergkeller autoclick nur noch
weg vor ihr ford field janecek kilo er
passt auf jeden fall gut nicht zuletzt
hacker ok dann bringen
ok-chef auch nur noch weg alles klar
ja das ist auch sehr viel kilogramm
wodka laura nur noch back for speed the
run objekt es aber keine beyblade
deshalb kein bergleute hierzu punkte
paris kay sechs richtige antworten
note 1 wird sagen 3 x 2 durch die
beantworten heißt note 1 oder wie seht
ihr es jetzt anders jetzt in die
kommentare nicht ab es war ein ziemlich
stammt von wir sehen uns hier die mingus
und das video heißt hacker in jump
league dazu noch eine kurze anmerkungen
leute also es ist wirklich so dass sie
80 prozent aller material mir
zugeschickt werden entweder tirolia oder
bett wars sind weil ich ein bisschen
abwechslung einbringen möchte nämlich
dann auch vorzug mal hacks aus anderen
spielmodi weil immer nur bis etwas ist
auch langweilig finde ich cool ein
bisschen durchmischt und auch mal so 61
stunden später ok schau mal rein
na ja da haben auch die rektoren
verdächtigen
na ja der kopf sich so ein bisschen
komisch aussehen dem fall quasi das
alter diese kreatur qual hat einfach so
eine 8 blog range what love is ja
natürlich echte schlägt ihnen anzusehen
und selbstverständlich creepy aus comics
kommt darüber gießen lauf lauf der junge
jetzt kommt eine mediabus und der hacker
wird weggeklappt sehr schön alles leider
setzte die ultra schlechte killer
roboter hell schlägt aber die ganze
energie getroffen
dieses app ob wir es also leute sowieso
würd ich mir hexen vorstellen wenn es
damals zu der zeit auch noch ein hexen
geglaubt hat schon hacker gegeben hätten
schon kräftig limette wenn wir das so
der der hexen heck gewesen so weiß
sowieso klick so ein bisschen verstohlen
schleicht zu durch die gegend und damit
der achse
ich frage mich immer bei solchen leuten
wo es so ob wir es ist so offensichtlich
dass sie hätten entweder sie sind
richtig dumm oder sie haben sowie
gestellt für die hacker das weiß man
halt nie meine muss einfach nur irgend
jemand der auch nur annähernd mit recht
hat dass sie den typen lifetime angeben
er jetzt kommt wir diese alternative
chaos egal
es gibt auch keine endlose anzahl an
minecraft bekannt wird dann bald man
eben jeden einzelnen lifetime mäßig so
und dann gibt's halt kein accounts mehr
richard soll ich meine jeder der
irgendeine deppen sein account daten
gibt weil er sich um ihn heck kaufen
will
das ist selbst schuld ganz ehrlich also
wenn man sich auf so etwas einlässt dann
muss man damit rechnen dass man seinen
account verliert ist einfach doppelt
soviel dazu dass er meine meinung zu dem
thema wir springen jetzt zu platz nummer
drei eine nummer drei
ok platz 3 heißt hacker schott punkt
dreister hacker auf reifen bloc party
das ist modus den ich auch niemals leben
gespielt hab ich weiß nicht was er
machen muss aber scheinbar gibt auch da
leute die hacken
okay okay dass jetzt zwei leute sind ja
ok schauen wir es so dass ein teil des
bodens verschwindet so wie bei mario
party in diesem mini game ja ok alles
klar
ja wer kennt ihn nicht
wer kennt ihn nicht diesen klassischen
bett wars zurück teleportiert manche
menschen ist ein oder andere sagen es
wäre der fix für den flyer heck der 1
zurück deportierten leute nutzen das aus
so oder so die gestaltet ist auch sehr
fein hacken
der modus macht keinen sinn wenn man so
eine scheiße macht what the hell es geht
darum dass man ausschalten jemand runter
fehlten er kann jetzt einfach gar nicht
runterfallen kinder das kind die andere
zu ihrer herzlichen den computer gar
nicht
er ist nicht mal annähernd ein block in
der nähe aber er kann nicht runterfallen
bz wer fährt schon runter aber wieder
wiederholt er wiederholte portiert so
oder so ist es einfach die abmahnung die
spieler die jetzt wird die andere raus
und gewinnt die scheiße einfach man das
so bitter aber ohne witz agenda der weg
mit dem typen weg mit dem und angeles
kennt natürlich der klassiker
okay diese an seinem stand von abba stig
und heißt die hacker kängurus sind am
start
ihr könnt euch einfach was auch super
gegen hacker hilft einfach so einen
kleinen lego block neben so ein lego
block und den etwa die nase stecken
so wirkt wunder
ich lass mal lieber somit einfach das
video anschauen wie wir es sich leben
die nase zu stecken
ok also essen hier ein worst is to das
schöne killer okay jetzt ein hacker down
eine vom vom legitim
er ist schon weg ist bei 160 will dass
hacker einfach nur grottenschlecht sind
so ohne zwei aspekte die hacker des
todes weg das alles treffer hat sitzt
nicht mehr aber das alles treibt nur den
bau sehr recht du bist ein gutes game
der junge paravan hier zwei hacker gegen
sich und guckt zack zack zack bleibt die
richtig sauer weg in erster getötet und
er macht dabei irgendwelche komischen
geräusche sehr komische geräusche wird
wieder nahkampf gehen sagt janna kampf
gegen kinder was immer nur schlechte
idee eine ganz ganz schlechte idee ja
als
es schlägt eiskalt durch die wand dessen
zwei drei blöcke dazwischen schlägt ihn
einfach durch also das ist jetzt
wirklich der allerletzte beweis dafür
dass er dran und über von der killer hat
durch zwei drei blöcke an wand hier
sitzen rechts ist vielleicht sogar noch
mehr schlägt aber warum eigentlich
känguru also bis jetzt noch nichts
er hat vor dem ausdrücklich in die
beschreibung geschrieben dass er keinen
jump boost kid hatte also etwas jump
boost hacks das ist wirklich extrem nie
was gehört also irgendwie ich weiß nicht
theoretisch könnte er den double jump
aktiviert haben
und er ist es aber seine leiche springt
ja auch noch weiter hoch also bisher
gesehen ist gestorben sein toter
minecraft kindes immer noch hoch
gesprungen also also einmal ist er sein
eigenes kit und deswegen gäbe es da kein
schampus also er wüsste es weil es
allein es gibt mit standfuß dem
entsprechen würde mich mal interessieren
wie geht das
ist es ein hack oder ist es double jump
gibt es einen hack dafür dass man so
hoch springen kann oder ist ein
regulärer job will ich mir nicht ganz
sicher ja wie immer wenn ihr dazu
meinung habt damit in die kommentare
dann können wir darüber auch mal
diskutieren wie gesagt ich bin mir nicht
sicher
dann lassen wir die hacker kängurus in
meine ruhe und springt zum nächsten
platzen das ist schon platz eins haltet
euch fest ich habe ja gesagt das ist ein
hacker an bord wohin die vermuten würde
und ich glaube das trifft auch ganz gut
so leute ja ihr seht richtig wir sind in
der community wir sind in der community
in der hacker show ansammlung legt nahe
dass jemand in der community gehackt hat
was so der der gipfel der sinnlosigkeit
ist aber schauen sie stehen hier da
vorne an dieser screenshot box drei
leute drin
ja natürlich
junge was als ob organisiert sie die
screenshot buxhovi dreiseitel schmuggelt
sich in die screenshot boxerin wird no
clip läuft erfreulich die blicke durch
warum warum leute warum macht ihr so was
alles klar 3 später der typ steht immer
noch einen screenshot box
begleiter aktiviert und wofür die reise
heute in für ihn diesen menschen die
einfach in der community gehackt hat
da oben drücken geleitet durch die
gegend auch leute das ist so der
community
das tut mir in der seele weh heut aber
darüber jedoch nicht mehr raus will
jetzt auf jedem foto dabei sein soll ist
eine kurz schaden bekommen und ist
verschwunden wo sie hin
woanders hin und da ist er wieder alles
klar
ich habe schon so gemacht hast
vielleicht verschwunden wäre aber das
war so weit von dieser woche danke euch
fürs zuschauen wenn sich gefallen hat
dann lassen sonst habe ich nichts mehr
zu sagen würde ich gerne eine geschichte
erzählt kanal ok in diesem sinne alles
gut und schön sonntag montag 6